okay good afternoon it's a great
pleasure to be here thank you and can
you hear me yeah I've been asked to
speak about conservation education in
the United States and so I'm going to
focus on all the graduate programs but
particularly on our own I'd share the
art conservation department at the
University of Delaware where we have an
undergraduate program a master's degree
program excuse me which is jointly
sponsored with winter term museum and a
PhD in preservation studies I'm going to
focus primarily on masters level
training in the United States this is a
terminal degree in art conservation but
I did want to mention that in the United
States there's six or so undergraduate
programs that are focused on preparing
students for graduate education art
conservation where students take
required curriculum in chemistry in art
history and anthropology museum studies
studio art as well as gaining
conservation experience there are four
graduate programs master level programs
the United States which are listed here
at NYU Buffalo our program at winterthur
University of Delaware and UCLA Getty
and all these programs are similar in
many ways we work together very closely
we actually share curriculum we assess
where the field is going we even do
collaborative fundraising which is
really quite wonderful and then we're
different also so for example a UCLA
Getty program is focused primarily an
archaeological and ethnographic
conservation the NYU program the
students receive both a masters of
science and art conservation as well as
the Masters of Arts in art history but
what I think is so significant is the
way that we collaborate and collaborate
very effectively and we build our
curriculum in different ways but we're
often looking at a document which you
might find very interesting if you're
beginning to build a curriculum
elsewhere and that was essential
competencies in conservation that was
prepared by the American Institute of
conservation it begins to define 13
areas some of which are listed here and
here as well where you should build a
curriculum what are those key skills and
competencies that are required for entry
level conservators so this is a useful
document certainly for all of us in our
program at the University of Delaware we
offer a masters of science it's a
three-year program which is jointly
answered by University University door
and a museum as well this offers for
rich collaboration that research and
scholarship of a university the amazing
collections at winter term museum the
education development and and all the
other advocacy and community engagement
that goes in between we also take
advantage of course of the collections
there to build knowledge skills and
abilities among our students we accept
10 students every year our applicant
pool this year was 90 so it gives you an
idea sort of the range of the number of
students these are individuals who have
the required coursework in chemistry art
history studio art as well as
conservation experience we require 400
hours of experience but in fact this
year in interviewing students we had
many students who were applying who had
8,000 hours of experience in
conservation before going into graduate
school they're coming with a great
passion for the field with enormous
knowledge and skills and a real
commitment to working globally we rely
on partnerships to work that Ian spoke
about we're so grateful to Yale and
everything that they've done for our
students past and present these Museum
and cultural institution partnerships
are essential to the education and
training of our students and in all
cases we'll all the programs these
students receive a tuition scholarship
fellowship support as well as research
travel support in our program we train
individuals in a variety of areas it's a
three-year program you can major in
photographic conservation or paper
conservation in objects of all kinds
ethnographic modern and decorative arts
as well this slide I won't read it to
you but it begins to sort of
characterize what we're trying to
achieve in terms of critical thinking
and decision-making an understanding of
the broad range of materials that you're
likely to encounter as a conservator and
although it's for our program it's
certainly true of all the graduate
programs in the United States our
program as I said is a three-year
program of study during the first year
students are exposed to all areas of
conservation and what we call blocks so
we teach a paper blog photographic
conservation block of paintings block
and objects block where they learn about
these materials what they are how they
deteriorate how to preserve them
scientific concepts associated with
their care they learn about advocacy and
public engagement as well I teach the
photographic conservation block that's
my field and so in that
case I want to ensure that all of these
students whether they major in
photography or not have a broad
understanding of the different materials
negatives and prints by the way that's
my grandson there and digital on the on
the right but everything from the
daguerreotype to the digital print
during the last photograph conservation
blocks we've also been involved in
emergency response and preparedness the
last two years we've worked to recover
three hundred photographs one year
damaged in a fire and the following year
in a flood we believe very strongly in
the importance of community engagement
and connecting to these activities and
sharing our knowledge and skills and
learning from those experiences in very
significant ways during the second year
the students are focused in their
discipline what they're going to major
in learning about scientific concepts
about the treatment ethical decision
making epics and philosophy associated
around their majors here are just some
of my favorite most recent projects by
Garrett Albertson before conservation
and after of course is not just about
conservation treatments about the
cultural context of scientific knowledge
advocacy and fundraising here at Bianca
Garcia who graduates this year before
and after treatment and then a project
done not too long ago in archaeological
glass again we're focused of course on
billing these hand skills but building
critical thinking skills as well and
finally in the third year the students
are involved in internships off-site
that are 11 months in length that
cultural institutions really around the
world where they are involved in the
practical application developing their
skills and knowledge and professionalism
and just one other project in textile
conservation of the Victoria and Albert
Museum before and after treatment we
believe strongly in the importance of
global engagement and we try to ensure
that their opportunities for our
students to work collaboratively and
globally as well we're grateful to the
Samuel H cross foundation who has
supported this initiative for many years
where students can spend summers working
around the globe most recently one of
our students and photographed
conservation was in Beirut working on
disaster preparedness with the Arab
image foundation and and they really
work all over the world in that regard
in terms of graduate placement on behalf
of all our programs i'm very happy to
say that our students do receive jobs
and fellowships after they finish their
masters training many of the students
eventually go on to work privately 51
percent of our alums are working in the
private sector
but others and so it's very important
that we're engaging them and connecting
them to all different aspects of
conservation building them as advocates
and fundraisers and and building their
time management skills and their
commitment to community engagement as
well as their skills in conservation and
finally of course we believe strongly in
the importance of partnerships and we
have been working recently thanks to
support from the mellon Foundation with
historically black colleges and
universities building awareness about
the preservation of their photographic
and now audio-visual collections
connecting our students to their
students trying to inspire their
students to think about careers in art
conservation and around the globe as
well we've been working in Erbil Iraq
we've developed with other partners
certainly and Institute training Iraqis
and the preservation of cultural
heritage on the left and on the right is
a slide from our work in the Middle East
we're working closely with the Arab
image foundation to build awareness
around the importance of photographic
conservation this project particularly
funded by the mellon Foundation as well
and in collaboration with the Getty
conservation Institute more recently
we've been working in Africa to try and
build awareness around photographic
conservation in sub-saharan Africa here
is a course in the School of African
heritage in Baneen so finally
fundraising of course is very key in all
these efforts and very rewarding as well
and we work across the spectrum with
foundations corporations individuals
government agencies and we're grateful
to their support and all of these
activities whether they're supporting
students for research travel or stipend
support finally just a few other remarks
here it is so important in developing
this curriculum that you continue to
revise it that you ensure that you're
meeting the needs of the field in a very
powerful way that you consult with your
lumps and the field more general and
allied professionals to address a
curriculum for example we're beginning
to doing do more now and preventive
conservation to do more with new
technologies to do more with modern and
contemporary art and we need to ensure
that our students are well prepared to
meet these emerging global needs
partnerships of course as you heard from
in and you'll hear from me and probably
every speaker here so essential
collaboration is is very important
advocacy is critical that we're
graduating individuals who can advocate
for the preservation of cultural
heritage
we're working with them to do that and
encouraging what's most rewarding and my
mind is really global engagement and we
try to do that as well so that's it I
did 40 slides I think I might have been
over by 10 seconds but I tried to do my
best thank you so much for your
attention